a havaiana me deu agora um chinelo que
eu não desejo que a sua mãe saiba que
existe é muito bom para pisar para andar
realmente a sensacional agora nas costas
só ai
porque tudo na vida o dinheiro tem uma
decisão sensacional porque nem tudo
Afinal dele para si próprio aquela mesmo
que você pensou assim eu me deu vontade
de ter uma casa só para dizer assim Tira
esses pés imundos da minha casa praia
hoje eu tenho mais de uma casa eu nunca
mandei ninguém sair de dentro da minha
casa que eu descobri que eu não consigo
velho mas a minha vontade Inicial era de
humilhar alguém entendeu para você me
esnobou na escola venha tomar do meu
balãozinho Você está vendo que tipo de
roupa não precisa coisa de gente que tem
muita grana hein Hahaha
Mas não dá meu irmão Esse é o problema
Eu acho que eu não seria era famoso
[ __ ] famosa que só Hum que não dá para
fazer as coisas normal do povo aí não